que de chemin parcouru depuis 2017
j'entends encore vos slogans de campagne
il faut en finir avec le vieux monde il
faut remettre les francs seraient au
coeur de la politique
les français attendent que les pratiques
de leurs responsables politiques
deviennent plus représentative plus
responsable et plus efficace monsieur le
premier ministre
avez-vous l'objectif objectivement
l'impression d'avoir atteint ses
objectifs
j'entends les retraités les
automobilistes avec les 80 kilomètres
heure certains de vos députés les
conseillers départementaux et bien
d'autres tous déçus j'entends c'est
gilet jaune des familles qui n'ont
jamais manifesté
mais qui ne supporte plus l'augmentation
des carburants et des taxes ces familles
qui travaillent qui sont à découvert le
20 du mois
et puis ces mères qui ont perdu leur
liberté d'agir qui ont des budgets en
baisse mais qui reste responsable de
tout même des catastrophes
ces mères écureuils qui ne veulent pas
renouveler leur mandat en 2020 vous
entendez monsieur le premier ministre
vous entendez mais vous n'écoutez pas de
plus en plus nous avons l'impression
d'être tous ensemble dans un avion le
président et vous monsieur le premier
ministre
enfermé dans le cockpit les français
tous passagers aux commandes
vous luttez pour ne pas perdre de
l'altitude mais rien n'y fait la
croissance est en berne le chômage reste
au même niveau la balance du commerce
extérieur est toujours négative
les dépenses de l'état augmentent le
sentiment d'insécurité persiste
la porte est close vous ne répondait
plus aux passagers qui s'inquiètent
vous en voyez pourtant par moment vos
chefs de cabine comme madame le ministre
de la cohésion des territoires pour nous
dire que tout va bien ou le ministre de
l'intérieur pour vérifier que nos
ceintures sont bien attachés que
personne ne bouge même votre ancien
premier ministre de l'intérieur l'a
compris et il a pris son parachute
alors juste une question quand allez
vous comprendre que vous niez un vrai
pas seuls merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur marc fesneau
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président rassurez
vous c'est ma dernière intervention
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur séguin a plu après vous avez
région monsieur karoutchi
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur je vais essayer de
répondre concrètement à votre question
en particulier sur le malaise des élus
locaux vous avez tout à fait raison
ne croyez pas et je ne crois pas avoir
entendu dans les propos du président de
la république hier que nous comprenions
pas la situation que nous l'apercevions
pas aussi bien que celles que vous
décrivez la vérité c'est que nous sommes
dans une situation où les élus locaux se
trouvent pour bien des sujets dans des
situations d'impasse et d'impuissance
par rapport à ce qu'ils voudraient faire
dans une situation d'impasse sur la
transition écologique dans une situation
d'impasse sur les transports dans une
situation d'impasse sur la
désertification médicale dans une
situation d'impasse gelé vécu dans ma
propre commune sur le haut débit et que
croyez vous que le gouvernement fait le
plan 3 milliards 2,3 milliards d'euros
sur le haut débit qui seront déployés
pour faire en sorte qu'en 2020 et 2022
et là ce ne sont pas des vaines
promesses c'est la réalité des choses et
ce sont des actes grecs ont créé la fin
du numerus clausus à la perspective de
la rentrée pour faire en sorte qu'il y
ait plus de médecins sur les territoires
et le déploiement sous des formes
nouvelles de médecins dans les
territoires alors oui on ne résoudra pas
tout en quelques instants quelques mois
parce que il ya des réformes
structurelles qui sont menées par ce
gouvernement
et c'est sans doute excusez moi de vous
le dire parce que ces réformes
structurelles n'ont pas été faites avant
que nous sommes dans la situation que
vous décrivez est que vous décrivez fort
justement alors nous prenons notre part
de responsabilité le sienna d'ailleurs
l'a fait sur un certain nombre de textes
en votant des propositions qui avaient
été portées par cette majorité et c'est
une bonne chose quand on peut se
retrouver et vous me permettrez enfin
monsieur le sénateur et monsieur le
président de de vous dire quelque chose
de ce que je perçois la situation du
moment de l'attention qu'on doit porter
à la situation du moment et le climat
qui règne aujourd'hui sur les
territoires et au niveau national à
l'endroit des élus locaux et des élus de
la nation
il n'est pas acceptable qu'on insulte
qu'on un timide ou qu'on menace des élus
locaux comme des élus de la nation
il n'est pas acceptable que l'on voit
fleurir sur des réseaux sociaux des
appels à la haine des appels à la
destruction
c'est valable
c'est valable c'est valable à la fois
pour les élus locaux et les élus
nationaux et moi je pense que quand on
attaque les élus locaux comme les
parlementaires de la majorité ou
l'opposition les élus locaux comme les
élus nationaux c'est la république on
l'attaqué c'est elle qu'il faudra
défendre au-delà des mesures qu'il
faudra faire et prendre pour répondre
aux angoisses de nos concitoyens je vous
remercie
c'est